Jason you you only just got to Britain
yeah I've been here for probably a week
okay but you seem to like it here
you you go out and about yes yes I'm
known for my shenanigans yes because we
spotted you around London with your
widow from a game of Thrones yes Amelia
o'clock she posted this picture of the
two of you was it this last week that
was like three days ago I just actually
flew over to Belfast
I got back from Belfast right now okay
so Belfast in November why are you
wearing a vest or a turtleneck well my
mother's gonna be very proud of me but
I'm gonna be it's gonna be close from
peeling this off and
[Applause]
[Applause]
but fans must go crazy when they see the
two of you together
I don't crazy when I see her do they
want you to start talking in it is it
Dothraki don't write here it's all
nonsense but you do speak some Dothraki
no no yes a few things go and then for
the ladies ginger on that day only and
for the gentleman
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you